hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast modeling and dissecting
hepatocellular carcinoma dies
dissemination I'm Judy or Oracle a
bird's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's webcast is
presented by lab routes comm the leading
social media site for science
professionals this presentation has been
approved for continuing educational
credits if you want to obtain the
credits please click on me get your free
cm ECE credits button located in the
lower left of your screen this will take
you to the continuing education page
where you can select a speaker click on
the CEC Emmy button and it will take you
through the process to obtain your
certification before we start there are
a few instructions we want to hear from
you during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers welcome to you can do
this by hitting the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right we use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenter we are proud to
welcome Brian Lewis PhD associate
professor of molecular cell and cancer
biology at the University of
Massachusetts Medical School dr. Lewis
received his PhD from Johns Hopkins
University and has performed
postdoctoral studies at the National
Institutes of Health and Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center supported
by a Helen hey Whitney foundation
postdoctoral fellowship he joined the
program in gene function and expression
at the University of Massachusetts
Medical School as an assistant professor
in 2003 research in dr. Lewis's lab
focuses on dissecting the molecular
mechanisms underlying the development
and progression of pancreatic and
hepatocellular cancers with a goal of
informed
effective targeted therapeutic
approaches I will now turn it over to
dr. Lewis thank you very much and thank
you everyone for attending today's talk
I hope it be very informative for you
and we will try to leave lots of time at
the end to address as many of your
questions as we can but today I want to
talk with you about how does within my
lab we're trying to model and dissect
the dissemination of the patio cell
carcinoma I hope to convey to you during
this talk why we think this topic is
particularly important and how we think
that this might address the very
critical clinical need entreat in
hepatic malignancies in patients so
before I started just wanted to make the
obligatory disclosure I have none to
make I do not get money from private
companies all the work that i will talk
about is funded either by the national
institutes of health or by private
nonprofit foundations the disease we're
going to talk about today Cepeda cell
carcinoma it's a leasing leading cause
of cancer-related death both in the
United States and worldwide and you can
see from this slide that worldwide is
the second leading cause of death among
men and the sixth leading cause of death
among women and approximately there over
half a million people who die from this
disease worldwide the leading causes of
underlying causes of this malignancy are
due to chronic liver insufficiency or
chronic liver inflammation scarring and
cirrhosis in chronic hepatitis B and
hepatitis C virus infections are the
primary cause of this worldwide in the
United States and other Western
countries in Western Europe for example
there are other significant causes
associated with alcohol use
other ideologies that induce liver
cirrhosis and damage now importantly
this is a cancer with very poor
prognosis the average of survival after
diagnosis with HCC is approximately one
year and for those patients who are
eligible to undergo a curative resection
of their tumors or surgical removal of
their tumors at this average survival
then increases to approximately two
years now very importantly for
understanding this disease or for
thinking about this disease if a patient
presents with disease that has invaded
into vascular structures outside of the
liver or if this patient presents with
disease that has spread to other tissues
and side the liver then these patients
are no longer candidates for surgical
resection in currently surgical
resection or liver transplantation are
the only potential curative treatments
that we have available all of our other
treatments that we utilize to a very
large extent have the ability to extend
survival but they are by no means
curative and patients who receive these
treatments will ultimately die from
their disease so the statistics are from
the american cancer society and they
highlight some of what i just told you
and so in the upper panel on this slide
you'll see the statistics for incidents
of pancreatic cancer in the united
states and at the bottom you'll see the
statistics for death rates and so what
you'll notice from what I just showed
you is that the among the top ten
leading causes or top 10 incidents
cancers in the United States that liver
tumors are not within the top 10 but we
think about the number of deaths that
you can see that among men liver cancers
are
the fifth leading cause of death among
men and the ninth leading cause of
cancer-related deaths among women in
these statistics again highlight what I
just told you in the previous slide
which is that liver cancers are very
poor prognosis and aggressive
malignancies and therefore for us
understanding how these malignancies
progressed to an unresectable state is
very important for improving these
statistics so this slide shows a
schematic and very schematic form this
progression of liver cancer and so we
start by our primary ideologies whether
the chronic hepatitis virus infection
other causes of liver inflammation and
scarring as such aflatoxin toxicity
alcohol induced injury and these
ideologies then induce a cyclist
self-reinforcing cycle of proliferation
sell debt fibrosis and scarring and when
we have that cycle of proliferation cell
death and scarring then we eventually
transition to a state where we have
abnormal liver cells that exist within
the liver in a state in which we have
lots of extracellular matrix deposition
lots of fibrosis lots of scarring and
what we see in this particular context
then is the onset of liver insufficiency
and the liver itself is a vital organ
and so if we have liver insufficiency
this could be bad within this context of
liver fibrosis and cirrhosis we then get
the induction of B hyperplastic state
hypoplastic nodules which can then
undergo by a genomic instability
transition into this plastic nodules
shown here in green additional genomic
instability loss of critical factors
such as p53 and activation of tumor
promoting factors such as pi3 kinase
signaling and then we get beyond set
the pedicel of carcinoma so importantly
then what we have been thinking about
within the lab is how it is that you
transition from this state to a state
where the tumors then spread to
additional organs and so this process of
tumors of tumor spread or metastasis is
a multi-step process and again this is a
cartoon form from a review published
several years ago by Josh fiddler and
the Anderson Cancer Center in Houston
and it shows you this progression of a
primary tumor that is localized within
the tissue is here in the upper left in
the various steps that it progresses
through to finally it gets to a
metastatic disease which in this case is
seeded the lungs of the patient and so
during this a multi-step process we have
to have the induction of Newcastle
assure of angiogenesis the cells have to
detach from their primary site and then
they undergo a process of invading into
the vasculature surviving that
vasculature arriving at a new site and
essentially undergoing a reverse
invasion process and migration process
where they moved from that vasculature
into the new site such as the lungs in
bamberg go through a series of steps
where they've been proliferate induced
new blood vessels and form a new lesion
within this tissue such as the lungs now
again as I point out before for
hepatocellular carcinoma this process if
it occurs even if it happens in a
relatively early phase such as here we
see served in this Center top section
where we talk about the catchment
invasion and this occurs into a portion
of the portal vein so
along the primary blood vessels of the
liver if it occurs into region of the
portal vein that is outside of the
livers what we might call extra hepatic
portal vein invasion from a clinical
treatment standpoint this is very much
like having disseminated disease that
has gone to the lungs and these patients
are therefore ineligible for either
surgical resection of their tumors or
for liver transplantation and again
these patients have extremely poor
prognosis and so within our laboratory
we've been very interested in trying to
understand the pathways that are
involved in promoting this progression
and promoting the metastasis of
hepatocellular carcinomas and so were
contributed by my alive and by several
other labs around the world have
identified several factors that are
involved in this process and on the
slide I'm just going to show you three
of these factors they're listed here and
these are the ones that my lab has
contributed significantly to and so
early work has shown that loss of the
p53 tumor suppressor gene is not readily
found in early liver cancer lesions but
is found in advanced liver cancer
lesions suggesting that loss of this
critical tumor suppressor may play an
important role in the progression of
disease and in fact in metastasis and by
maudlin p53 tumor suppressor gene loss
in the mouse we were able to show the
loss of p53 in fact promotes
dissemination of liver tumors in
portland are in our studies we found
that loss of p53 did not impact the
development of liver cancers so we had a
similar rate of tumor formation in the
presence or absence of p53 function the
absence of p53 function readily promoted
the dissemination of these liver tumors
to the lungs suggestion that p53
inactivation plays a critical role
this process of hcc dissemination
additional work from our lab as well as
others then demonstrated a critical role
for igf2 mediated signaling through the
or instant light growth factor-2
signaling through its cognate receptor
the instant light growth factor-1
receptor and again work from our lab
demonstrated that activation of this
signaling axis does not impact features
associated with tumor initiation but
greatly impacted tumor progression and
features associated with that included
as shown on the previous slide tumor
cell migration and tumor cell invasion
and so we had this previous data in
there again additional data that are
present in the literature but we really
became interested in trying to identify
novel factors I might regulate these
processes and so a postdoctoral fellow
in the lab yawen Chen went to the
process several years ago of trying to
identify cell lines hepatocellular
carcinoma cell lines that might have
differential expression that correlated
with their phenotypes in cell culture
surrogate assays that we use to measure
features associated with tumor
dissemination and so shown on the slide
is a cartoon version of an acid that we
use which is a transwell my creation
assay and the way that this particular
assay works is that we place cells in
the in an insert that's a present within
a tissue culture well the cells are
plated on top and they adhere to a
membrane that coats the bottom of this
insert and this membrane then has very
small pores in cells are able to migrate
through and get to the other side and so
depending on how well these cells are
able to move were to migrate
you get different numbers of cells that
appear at the underside of this well
then you can count dissolves and
determine how many cells had migrated
through and use it as a surrogate
measure of the ability of these cells to
migrate and therefore potentially to
metastasize if they were in vivo and so
what we did was in to take a cell line
that we generated from our mouse model
this particular cell line it was called
BL 185 at this particular cell line
although it is p53 know this tumor did
not metastasize in vivo and in our
transwell a say that these cells had
very poor migration activity and so what
yawen did then was to take this the
sunlight put it through the assay and
then she identified the cells that had
appeared on the underside of this
membrane to cells that had successfully
migrated through in this assay took
these sobs isolated them and expanded
that in culture and so two of these
subpopulations that she identified she
called bill 185 m 1 and BL 185 i won and
so what she found that if you then take
these cells and put them through our
translate a say that these subclones
that she identified and inherently
enhanced cell migration activity and so
the question that she wanted asked was
then what are the differences between
these populations between these highly
migratory populations and one and i won
and what are the gene expression changes
that have occurred in common between
these two cell lines that's different
from what occurs in the parental one and
so this is where a grad that student in
the lab leann Aronian came in and we and
performed a fo metrics microarray a gene
expression profiling and so when she did
this profile and experiment she
identified
over 300 genes that had very significant
gene expression changes as assessed by a
two-fold or more change in expression
and an adjusted p-value of less than
point 01 and so when we looked at the
gene ontology or go term annotations of
these genes we identified many genes and
many processes that had been previously
linked to tumor cell migration and tumor
metastasis and so among these were the
EMT factor twist to the transcription
factor hit one alpha and importantly a
factor identified previously by Scott
Lowe's group up at Cold Spring Harbor
DLC one that had been shown to correlate
and associate with hepatocellular
carcinoma of invasion and progression in
vivo and so these fine isn't suggested
to us that our data center gene
expression data set was in fact a
request one and then might then identify
for us high value novel players in these
processes and so one of the factors of
interest to us was a transcription
factor called Calif 6 or Google light
factor six so Caleb six is easing finger
transcription factor if we assay Calif
six expression by comparing the
expression again in these highly
migratory invasive subclones the m1 and
Iowans subclones compared to the parent
that Calif 6 expression was greatly
reduced in those sub phones relative to
the parent and if we looked by western
blotting you can see in the panels to
your right we can see that again by the
protein level and not just at the
messenger RNA levels we see in the left
and panels that the protein level kluv
six expression as fast and reduced in
this highly migratory and invasive HTC
cells again relative to the parental
control so again
is kayla six so it's a sink finger
transcription factor it's important for
development so homozygous Lee deleted
mice are died during embryonic
development chalo six have been shown to
act as a tumor suppressor in several
human cancers and decreased Caleb six
expression correlates with atc prognosis
now Caleb six is a transcriptional
regulator which can act as both an
activator in a repressor and several of
its targets such as ich adhering and
matrix metalloproteinase-9 our mmp-9
have been previously suggested to play
critical roles in tumor metastasis in
vivo so if we look at the schematic in
the bottom right we can see some
critical features of kale or six I just
want to highlight a couple of these for
you so first as a transcription factor
as a nuclear localization signal that
leads to its import into the nucleus the
c-terminal portion of the protein is
where the zinc-finger binding domains
are encoded and you can see that these
are encoded across three separate exons
in the gene now importantly at the top
here we have the wild-type version of
kale 06 but there are also several
splice variants of kale 06 that have
been identified in vivo and critically
one of these has been very much been
correlated with tumor development and
tumor the presence of tumors in vivo and
in human patients including hcc patients
and this is the so-called sv1 or splice
variant one now critically for killer
success v1 this these c-terminal as in
finger domains are not present but in
fact instead there's an alter an
alternate splicing event that then leads
to a truncated domain that does not
contain these say fingers
and therefore sv1 is not able to bind to
DNA and regulate gene expression and so
the sp1 splice variant is believed to be
a dominant-negative or tumor promoted
form of caleb six so again previous work
from scott friedman at mount sinai in
New York had shown that klf4 six
expression decreases as you go across
the spectrum of hcc until in normal
tissues they're relatively high Caleb
six levels in calif six levels decrease
until they can find extremely low levels
in advanced hcc now important if you
plot patient survival those patients
that have higher chalo six expression as
such as though so shown here have higher
and better prognosis than those patients
who have very low calif six expression
and so these data point out or suggest i
should say a potentially a critical role
for loss of calif six function and
promoting the progression of
hepatocellular carcinoma so we Leanne in
my lab that undertook an analysis annu
analysis of calif six expression in accs
and justice Scott Friedman's lab found
as she found that there is decreased
expression of kale 06 messenger RNA in
hepatocellular carcinomas relative to
the normal liver importantly Leanne
found that if we compare different
subsets of hepatocellular carcinomas
that those at paracellular carcinomas
that demonstrated invasion into the
portal vein and reduced levels of kayla
six mrna compared to those that did not
display invasion into the portal vein
suggesting that loss of klf six is
correlated with a more aggressive
disease it's able to invade
fearful renders these patients
ineligible for curative tumor resection
so to begin to dissect how caleb sex
might affect these processes which
performed shrna mediated knockdown of
care of six and on the left you can see
the Western blots demonstrated effective
knockdown of KLF 60s in two independent
shrna s and a consequence of caleb six
knock down the shield on the right in a
transformation as a a soft target colony
formation assay you can see that loss of
caleb six a reduction of klf six
expression leads to enhance
transformation so needs to increase the
numbers of colonies in this
anchorage-independent assay now
pertinent to the phenotype of greatest
interest to us the ability of these
tumor cells to metastasize we then put
the killer 6 knockdown cells and
controls through our trans love
migration assay and the results from one
such experiment are shown here and
quantified form it's a again both shrnas
that reduced kale or six expression and
lead to an increase in tumor cell
migration in this trans velocity
relative to the controls and so these
data suggest that loss of calif sex
function or or inhibition of calif six
function leads to enhanced cell
migration and potentially to enhance
tumor metastasis in vivo and so then we
decided to model loss of tick of caleb
six in vivo to directly address this
question does loss of caleb sex lead to
increasing hepatocellular carcinoma
metastasis in vivo and so i want to
introduce you to the model system that
we use with these experiments this is
the arc as TBA modeling system in this
system has two essential components the
first essential component is an arc as
vector and that's based on the avian
leukosis virus this is an avian
retrovirus
we infects animals of avian species and
the second critical aspect of this model
is the receptor called TBA and so TBA
receptor as the factor to which lb or
avian leukosis viruses bind and this
allows their internalization into the
cell now importantly mammals such as
mice humans do not have the gene that
encodes for TVA and so mammalian cells
mirian cells are insensitive to
infection or cannot be infected by avian
leukosis viruses or our past viruses
however if we drive expression of the
receptor in a transgenic animal we can
then render particular tissues within
the mouse susceptible to infection by
our cast viruses and so in the case of
our HCC model we drive expression of the
TB a transgene using an albumin promoter
and enhancer element such that only the
hepatocytes and their precursors within
the liver express TBA and are
susceptible to infection by our cast
viruses we have previously published
this model about a decade ago in a paper
published in molecular cell biology or
MCB so the strategy that we then use for
modeling HCC's in the system is then to
generate a transgenic line that I told
you about the albumin TV a transgenic
line within utilize our cast viruses
encoding and anchor gene called mouse
polyomavirus middle t antigen shown here
and we utilize this oncogene because it
activates several signaling pathways
including the pi3 kinase akt signaling
pathway that we know are activated in
hepatocellular carcinomas again the
strategy is to take these viruses and in
our case we actually take chicken
fibroblasts sewn on tumorigenic chicken
fibroblasts that are produced in our
archives virus and we check the
either into the liver or into the
peritoneal cavity of a TB a transgenic
mouse and then we allow these mice to
age and analyze and for tumor
development and so again here is the
strategy what our previous data had
shown is if we take our gas viruses and
choline palio middle team and we inject
them into an element TV a mouse and
these mice develop tumors for these
tumors do not be taught not to not
metastasize they stay in Thailand in the
liver however if we additionally delete
p53 either through germline deletion of
p53 or by using conditional deletion of
p53 specifically within the liver again
we do not enhance the formation of
tumors so we promote their metastasis to
the lungs and so some of these data are
shown from our original publication on
this model are shown in this table again
you can see that my salon wildlife of
p53 efficiently developed tumors but
they very rarely metastasize to the
lungs in contrast those tumors that are
deficient for p53 do not show an
increased rate of tumor formation of far
more readily metastasize to the lungs
and these data suggest a critical world
for p53 inactivation and promoted tumor
metastasis and so this model system then
provides an effective tool in which
through which we can then model tumor
metastasis in hepatocellular carcinoma
and so then the question we wanted to
ask is if we delete a single allele of
kale and six that would mimic the
reduced Caleb six expression that is
observed in hepatocellular carcinoma
patients can we then promote the
progression of tumor metastasis in vivo
and so if we do that experiment and
again I should highlight here that in
all cases these tumors ultimately end up
being null for p53
and then they have altar in calif six
status either wild-type for Caleb six
were deleted for a single copy of kayla
six if we do that that we identify that
those tumors that are wild type for
Caleb six or those mice that are wild
backpack a lipsticks in the liver have
enhanced survival welded to those mice
that have deleted a single copy of kale
f6 within the liver interestingly one of
the things that we found which is
frankly in contrast what we expected was
that the histology with tumors that form
does not change so loss of KL f6 loss of
a similarly love Caleb six does not
impact installed in the tumors that form
however we found that Caylor six
wild-type tumors failed to metastasize
in this particular cohort while those
that lack a single allele of Kayla six
red limit as a size to the lungs and so
here is Paris on histology images here
is the single metastatic focus that we
identified in a kale of six wild-type
tumor and shown in the additional panels
are some of the examples of lung
metastases that we identified in mice
that were heterozygous repeated excuse
me heterozygous for calif sexy and these
data just sort of shown here for you in
quantitative form that in no instance in
where we are in a single instance we
identified hepatocellular carcinomas and
halo 6 wild-type livers they be
identified grossly visible metastases to
the lungs and the single focus that I
showed you is actually identified upon
sectioning through the entire lungs to
identify that single focus whereas in
the case where we can meet a single copy
of calif six we readily identify
metastatic full side within the lungs
importantly if we look at gene
expression of various markers associated
with hcc progression and aggressive
disease and poor prognosis you identify
that for some of these markers including
a factor that we've previously
functional characterized idea too but if
you delete a single copy of KL f6 they
we see enhanced expression of these poor
prognosis genes in these tumors relative
to tumors that are wild type 4 kilo sex
and so we were then of trying to
understand how it is this enhancement
astuces might occur and so we return to
our cell culture studies we began to
look at factors that have been
previously associated with tumor
metastasis in vivo and tumor cell
migration and so this is a very busy
slide but I put it up here just to
highlight one thing for you which at
least this small GTP is called rac1 and
rac1 does several things within the cell
but while things that it does is it
impacts the actin cytoskeleton and
enhances a cell migration both in vitro
and in vivo and so we then asked can we
identify enhance activation of this
critical factor rac1 in the palace a low
carcinoma cells in which we have either
intact chalo 6 or cells in which we have
reduced pay less exposure using shrnas
and what we found is that we have
enhanced raglan activity in these cells
and also enhanced activity of a related
factor cdc42 in cells which we reduced
kaler 6 function importantly we were
able to show that rac1 function was
critical for a tumor cell migration so
I'll just have you folks on the panel on
the right that shows our migration data
and so if we look at paracellular
carcinoma cells that we've infected with
the control shrna they have the
migration a level of migration activity
that we've normalized one hundred
percent if we knock down Cael f6 they
can see that we increase that migration
activity but importantly we use it shrna
against rac1 you then reduce this
migration activity down to baseline
suggesting that rapid activity is
critical for this enhanced migration now
importantly I've shown you on the
previous slide that we also saw enhance
cdc42 activity in these cells but you'll
notice that we not that's easy for you
to do with shrnas that we do not impact
this tumor cell is enhanced to my cell
migration and so these data suggest that
really that rac1 is the primary driver
of timisoara equation downstream of KL
f6 knocked down and that's cdc42 does
not play a primary role although
additional data that will not show you
such as that there is in fact abode for
cdc42 in this process so again I showed
you before told you before that chalo
six is a transcription factor and so of
interest to us then was identifying the
target scalar six that might mediate
this process and so to do this we took
two approaches that we combined the
first was to do chromatin
immunoprecipitation or chip coupled to
deep sequencing and by this approach
will identify all the sites or many of
the sites throughout the genome at which
kayla six is found within hepatocellular
carcinoma cells we then combined that
data set with the gene expression
profiling data set where we compared the
expression profiles messenger RNA
expression profiles of hepatocellular
carcinoma cells with intact kaler 6 or
cells in which we use in shrna we've not
down calif six expression and then we've
intersected these two data
and so then the intersection of these
two data sets should identify for us a
collection of directly regulated calif
six target genes and hcc cells many of
which then will be predicted to regulate
tumor cell migration and so we
identified by this process we identified
approximately 60 chalo six target genes
and two of these target genes are 53 and
cdc42 eb3 and this is just a
quantitative PCR showing that when you
knock down chalo six years in shrna that
you increase the expression of both
cdc42 EP 3 and 5 3 at the messenger RNA
level if we focus in on boundary a
little bit more you can see the qpcr
data I showed you in the previous slide
and by western blotting again you can
see enhance 53 expression and cells in
which we reduced Caylor 6 activity using
shrna s now importantly we look at
tumors from our mouse model in which
you've deleted a single copy of pale f6
and compare those two tumors from our
mouse model in which Caleb 6 is intact
you can see that those tumors that lack
Kayla 6 have increased bad three
expression relative to their wild-type
counterparts suggesting that not only in
cell culture settings but also in vivo
that valve 3 levels are sensitive to
Caleb six gene dosage into Caleb's six
function so we then went on to ask the
about the role of klf six and excuse me
a fab 3 and kale f6 mediated migration
and so it looks like we have a small
pick up here so if you'll ignore on top
that should have been an immunoblot on
top that demonstrated affected by three
knockdown if we look at the lower panel
here what you'll see is again we have
caleb we have HTC cells with intact
k love six and this is their migration
activity if we knock down pls six again
we can see that we enhance that
migration activity but if we reduce
valve 3 function using shrnas that again
we revert that migration back down to
baseline suggesting that valve 3 is
required for this enhanced migration
downstream of Caleb 6 inactivation
similarly if we impaired cdc42 ep3
function we see a similar phenotype so
again using SI RNAs we can then reduce
the migration activity of these HCC
cells in which we've additionally gotten
rid of calif 6 function so i bring you
back to this a schematic slide this
cartoon in which i previously shown you
the presence of rac1 but what i wanted
to highlight for you here was the fact
that upstream of rac1 are the valve
proteins the valve proteins are guests
or groaning nucleotide exchange factors
for the rack proteins and what these
guests do then is to facilitate the
activation of rac1 such a it goes from a
gdp bound state which is inactive to a
GTP bound state that is acting so five
proteins and facilitate the exchange of
GTP for gdp and lead to wrap one
activation so again here we have
inactive round one is gdp-bound bathra
then facilitates the conversion to
activate it rac1 GTP so the only thing i
want to highlight for you here and this
is going to come up in the next few
slides are some of the functional
domains of bab three so bad three
belongs to a family of proteins the dbl
family of proteins excuse me my life is
run up
the dbl family of family of proteins and
so this DVL homology domain or the
so-called eh domain this is demand the
domain that is responsible for gtp
loaded onto rag1 and related proteins
and so excuse me and so then mutations
within this domain that in activate its
guests function or its nucleotide
exchange function would then be
predicted to inhibit radwin activation
similarly mutations within this
conserved ph domain or pleckstrin
pleckstrin homology domain ph domain
that facilitate the interaction of bath
proteins with phosphoryl
phosphoinositides that lead to their
recruitment to plasma membranes and
other membranes in which they actively
signal then would also be predicted to
impair the ability of bad proteins to
facilitate the exchange of gtp to GDP on
rag proteins and therefore inhibit rack
activation so that we look in hcc cells
in which we have inactivated kaler 6
using shrna and we additionally
inactivate valve 3 you can see that we
reduce the levels of requin activation
so in the left column here is the rapid
activation that's seen upon kaler 6
knockdown is normalized to 1 and if we
then again so this is our level of
activation normalized to one when you
inactivate kaler six if we additionally
inactivate valve 3 we reduce that
activation if in cells that have valve 3
not down we expect optically express
wild-type valve 3 we can restore to a
very large extent that rachlin
activation however immunes within the
gift domain or within the ph domain
failed to do so to the same
stem similarly we look at cell migration
again cells in which we have knocked
down chalo six have high migration
activity that we've normalized to 100%
if we knock down bab three we reduce
that migration activity by fifty percent
if we topically express in those cells
wild-type a three we restore
significantly that migration activity
but again our mutants in which we either
cannot we inactivate the gaff activity
or we block the ph domain then fail to
significantly rescue their migration
activity and so together with the data
on the previous slide these data then
suggest that bad three and importantly
it's a function serving as a gap for RAC
one then is required for cell migration
downstream of KLR six and so just to
quickly summarize that I told you today
we've demonstrated that reduced kill
expression correlates of extrahepatic
invasion in hcc patients and these
correlative data suggests that maybe
there is a potential role for kilo six
and promoting the progression of
metastasis of hcc in vivo in patients in
cell culture systems we've shown that
klf six regulates cell migration that
inactivation of klf six leads to enhance
migration phenotype associated with
enhanced metastasis concordantly we
delete klo six in vivo in a mouse model
we promote not only tumor formation we
promote metastasis of those tumors and
in trying to understand the mechanism by
which caleb such regulates these
phenotypes both in vitro and in vivo we
show that inactivation of kale f6 leads
to enhance requin activation in a manner
that is dependent on the rack one gift
that three in
quickly were able to show that vamp 3 is
required for HTC cell migration in this
in vitro transform migration assays so
finally I would like to thank the folks
who actually done the work almost all of
this work was driven by a single
graduate student Leanne aronian who has
now finished her PhD studies and is now
a postdoctoral fellow at Mass General
Hospital in Boston our bioinformatics
our gene expression profile and chip
seek data were analyzed by our colleague
here in our department Julie shoot and
the initial rac1 gtp Iraq would
activation assays were performed by our
colleague and collaborator yeah when
Chen hua now has her own lab at the
national health research institutes in
Taiwan and you may recall from the
beginning of my talk in fact that Yahweh
and initiated the studies on creating
and isolated these highly migratory
invasive subclones of the HTC cell line
that formed the basis for these initial
studies and finally I need to
acknowledge funding from the National
Cancer Institute at the National
Institutes of Health that has supported
our work financially and so with that
I'd like to say thank you for attending
this seminar and I look forward to
seeing your questions and answering them
thank you excellent presentation dr.
Lewis thanks for bringing that
information to us before we get started
with all of your questions here's a
quick reminder or how to reach us today
questions can be sent via the Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window we'll get to as many as we can
and give you a few moments to formulate
your questions
okay so if there are no questions today
I would like once again thank dr. Lewis
for his presentation do you have any
final comments dr. Lewis so I just like
again like say thank you very much for
participating certainly you may feel
free to reach out to through lab roots
with additional questions if you have
them and I just you know want to close
by again reemphasize in the clinical
significance of this question not only
for hepatocellular carcinoma but frankly
for other tumor types as well I think
really understanding how to michelle's
metastasize will be very critical for
our clinical management of these
diseases thank you just a reminder if
you wish to obtain the credits for
today's session please click on me get
your free cm ECE credits button located
in the lower left of your screen this
will take you to the continuing
education page where you can select a
speaker click on a cec emmy button and
be guided through the process to obtain
your certification today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through March 30th 2016 will receive an
email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand and posted on lab
routes comm Noor welcome to forward this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time